I'm up. I'm up. I'm up. Are we starting? What is this? Is anybody here? Hello? Oh, guys, nobody's here. This is weird. Finally. Just a moment of silence before we start the show. Oh, welcome to the Smiles. Smiles. Sean, congratulations on a very successful run of your show. You guys have rapped now, and do we know yet if we are traveling with this huge success? Yes, we are traveling to the Broadway. By the way, I didn't even tell you guys, there was a, there was a reviewer like three weeks ago that said, I'm not even making this up.
我醒了。我醒了。我醒了。我们要开始了吗？这是什么？这里有人吗？喂？噢，伙计们，这里没人。这太诡异了。终于。在节目开始前默哀一秒钟。哦，欢迎来到“微笑”。微笑。肖恩，恭喜你的节目大获成功。你们现在已经巡演结束了，我们现在知道我们要带着这个巨大的成功去哪里巡演吗？是的，我们要去百老汇。顺便说一句，我甚至都没告诉你们，大约三周前有个评论家说，我真的不是在瞎编。
He said, you know, he raved about the show and it was a really good report. Although, before they go to Broadway, they need to remove Sean's plastic wig and his fat suit, neither of which are true. No, no, no, no. So where'd he go? I'll send it to you. And I was like, wait, that's my real hair. And I'm actually really fat in life. No, you are not. Absolutely not. Well, you know my stomach. Plus, I'm wearing those old fifties clothes. So my stomach sticks out. Oh, well, why does that leave you? Isn't that hilarious? Well, you read that. What did you, what happened?
他说，你知道的，他对这部剧赞不绝口，这是一篇非常好的报道。不过，在他们去百老汇之前，他们需要去掉肖恩的塑料假发和他的胖子道具服，这两者都不是真的。不，不，不，不。那他去哪了？我发给你。当时我就想，等等，这是我的真发。而且我生活中其实真的很胖。不，你才不胖。绝对没有。好吧，你知道我的肚子的。另外，我还穿着那些五十年代的老旧衣服。所以我的肚子凸出来了。哦，好吧，这算怎么回事？这不是很搞笑吗？好吧，你看了那个。你，怎么了？
Wait, you're not wearing a fat suit? Sean, honestly, how did you feel, there it is. There it is. The cookie bag. The cookie bag. How did you feel after you read that? Yeah, it's hurtful. I laughed. What do I care? I mean, yeah. I have laughed too about reading some bad things about me, but it does leave you a little winded. I was fine with that. I really honestly, truly laughed. I think that's really funny that he thought I was wearing a fat suit and a plastic wig because my hair is shellacked. Well, I can't wait to see it in New York.
等等，你没有穿胖子道具服？肖恩，老实说，你感觉如何，来了。来了。饼干袋。饼干袋。你读完那个有什么感觉？是的，这很伤人。我笑了。我才不在乎呢？我是说，对。我也曾笑过关于我的一些负面报道，但它确实会让你有点喘不过气。我对此挺在乎的。我真的、老实说、打从心底笑了。我觉得他以为我穿着胖子道具服和塑料假发真的很好笑，因为我的头发抹了发胶。好吧，我等不及在纽约看了。
Will, I know you'll be there with me. I'm going to be there. I'm going to 100%. In fact, hang on, Will. Sean, is that a glass of milk that you're sipping? Listener, Sean's sipping a squat glass of milk. And I just, it just, I don't think I've ever seen anyone literally drink a glass of milk. Just on its own. Yeah. There's no peanut butter sandwich. Didn't that stop with the little newspaper boys on the corner selling papers for five cents? Isn't that the last time, last time I saw a glass of milk being. Say, mister, say, mister, over here, say, mister. Gee, it's neat to be a news boy. Hey, we know about it.
威尔，我知道你会陪着我的。我会去的。我100%会去。事实上，等等，威尔。肖恩，你手里端的是一杯牛奶吗？听众朋友们，肖恩正在小口喝着一杯敦实的牛奶。我只是，我只是，我觉得我从来没见过有人真的喝一杯牛奶。就单喝。是的。也没有花生酱三明治。这难道不是在街角卖五分钱一份报纸的小报童时代就绝迹了吗？难道那不是最后一次，我最后一次看到有人在喝……。听着，先生，听着，先生，这边，听着，先生。天哪，当个报童真酷。嘿，我们都知道。
It's a glass of milk. It's ice cold. It tastes so good. Ice cold glass of milk, huh? Just something for the cookie pouch down there. You know what I love? He's setting, he's. It's got to go with the cook. What do you call it? The cookie? What? Cookie bag, cookie pouch. He's just setting a nice base for something for the cookies to plop into, you know what I mean? Yeah, yeah. A nice pool. Oh, I love about you, Sean. God, you're so simple. It's unbelievable. Your guest must be furious at you by now, Will.
这是一杯牛奶。冰镇的。尝起来真好。冰镇牛奶，对吧？刚好配下面那个饼干袋。你知道我最喜欢什么吗？他在准备，他。这必须配饼干。你叫它什么？饼干？什么？饼干袋，饼干兜。他只是在为饼干掉进去垫个好底，你知道我的意思吗？对，对。一个漂亮的池子。哦，我最喜欢你的一点，肖恩。天哪，你太单纯了。简直难以置信。威尔，你的嘉宾现在肯定气死你了。
My guest, you know what? My guests are going to be furious. Double booking. If, if they were, if they were shitting people, if they were shitting, that was what I guess for you. Hull and Oat. We're going to keep guessing Hull and Oats until they come on the goddamn show. And, uh, you know, but you know what? These guys make music of a different kind. Oh, they make music with their art of a different kind. More of a visual art. These fellas, they like to take ideas.
我的嘉宾，你知道吗？我的嘉宾要气疯了。重复预定。如果，如果他们，如果他们在扯淡，如果他们在扯淡，那是我为你们猜的。霍尔与奥茨。我们要一直猜霍尔与奥茨，直到他们上这个该死的节目。而且，呃，你知道吗？这些家伙创作的是一种不同寻常的音乐。哦，他们用他们不同寻常的艺术创作音乐。更像是一种视觉艺术。这些家伙，他们喜欢收集创意。
Well, they like to write ideas and then they like to put them up on the big screen. That's right. These guys, and they like to do it. Lord Miller. They like to do it in every single discipline they've directed. Lots of movies, lots of movies that I've done, including Lego Movie and Lego Batman. I can't go any longer because you guessed it, it's Lord and Chris Miller. It's Hull and Oat. Look at them.
嗯，他们喜欢写下创意，然后把它们搬上大银幕。没错。这些家伙，他们喜欢这么做。洛德·米勒。他们喜欢在他们指导的每一个领域都这么做。拍了很多电影，我拍过很多电影，包括《乐高大电影》和《乐高蝙蝠侠》。我不能再继续卖关子了，因为正如你所猜到的，他们就是菲尔·洛德和克里斯·米勒。他们是霍尔与奥茨。看着他们。
I couldn't even get into the preamble. Well, who else is there? There's just, there's only two that know how to write it and put it up on the screen in its glorious form. Hull and Oats and us. How do you guys respond to that? You're the Hull and Oats of film. I mean, I take that as a huge compliment. I got so excited for two seconds when I thought I was Hull and Oats. Wait, which one, which one would you be?
我甚至都没法进入开场白。好吧，还有谁在？只有两个知道如何写出它并以辉煌的形式把它搬上银幕的人。霍尔与奥茨和我们。你们对此有什么看法？你们是电影界的霍尔与奥茨。我是说，我觉得这是一个巨大的赞美。当我还以为我是霍尔与奥茨的时候，我激动了两秒钟。等等，你是哪一个？
Yeah, which one would you be? I'm going to go with, I'm going to go with Daryl Hall. Daryl Hall and John Oats. Daryl is the Hutch, not the Starsky. Which one's Starsky? Daryl has the blonde hair and Oats has the mustache. Okay, so John Starsky, who's who then? I mean, you guys are both dark hair?
对，你是哪一个？我要选，我要选达里尔·霍尔。达里尔·霍尔和约翰·奥茨。达里尔是赫奇，不是斯塔斯基。哪个是斯塔斯基？达里尔有一头金发，奥茨留着胡子。好吧，所以约翰是斯塔斯基，那谁是谁？我的意思是，你们俩都是黑发？
Neither one, I guess I can grow a mustache easier, so I guess, but you have the curly hair, so like that's the most. It's a real dogfight. Yeah, let's take more time with this. Just, let's not rush into the answer. Hey, by the way, Jason, why don't you say that for your podcast, Grinding to a Halt, which starts next week on Wondery. Gentlemen, welcome.
哪个都不是，我猜我比较容易留胡子，所以我想，但你有一头卷发，所以这才是最……。这真是一场恶战。对，让我们在这个问题上多花点时间。只是，我们别急着回答。嘿，顺便说一句，杰森，你为什么不在你的播客《举步维艰》里说这个呢？该播客将于下周在Wondery上线。先生们，欢迎。
Yeah. Welcome to the show. I don't know how you find the time to spend a silly 60 minutes with us, but thank you. And why are you guys, where are you right now? We are in our office that is, we finished the week of March 2020 and never actually worked out of, and it's our first day here in the office, so. Is that true story? Yeah.
是的。欢迎来到节目。我不知道你们怎么能抽出宝贵的60分钟和我们在一起，但谢谢你们。还有，你们俩，现在在哪里？我们在我们的办公室，那是我们结束了2020年3月的那周后，就再也没有真正在这里工作过的地方，这是我们自那以后第一天来办公室，所以。这是真实的故事吗？是的。
True story. It's been awesome to pay the lease on this for the last two years. Yeah. How weird. Now, do you, for the last two years, you guys have been doing what you do remotely, or are you guys going over to each other's houses? We did, like, partially remotely. The things we've been working on recently are the sequel to Spider-Verse,
真实的故事。过去两年一直在为这个付租金，感觉真棒。是的。多奇怪啊。现在，你们，在过去的两年里，你们一直在远程做你们做的事情，还是说你们经常去彼此的家里？我们做了，类似半远程的。我们最近一直在做的事情是《平行宇宙》的续集，
which we've been going in on a couple days a week, and then we've been making this show, The After Party for Apple TV Plus, and we, you know, we shot that for real in person with real human beings. Now, do you guys prefer to be on the set and directing stuff and mixing with folks, or do you prefer that more typical sort of life of a writer, where it's just the two of you at a shared desk, looking at each other, pitching ideas, typing? That's right, arm and arm. One arm over Chris, the other on the keyboard.
我们一周会去那里几天，然后我们一直在为Apple TV Plus制作这部剧《浮华宴》，我们，你知道的，我们在现实生活中和真人一起拍摄了这部剧。现在，你们是更喜欢在片场导演东西并和大家打成一片，还是更喜欢那种更典型的作家生活，也就是你们两个人共用一张桌子，互相看着，推敲创意，打字？没错，手挽着手。一只手搭在克里斯身上，另一只手放在键盘上。
I do, the left side of the keyboard, he does the right side of the keyboard. Oh my God, you guys, no, no, no, that may be the thing. Don't you hate it when you go to a restaurant and you see that loving couple, and they're on the same fucking side of the booth, and they're not sitting face to face. They decide to sit hip to hip on the same side, looking out at the restaurant, letting everyone see how fucking in love they are. Hey, Jason, you know what?
我负责，键盘左侧，他负责键盘右侧。哦，天哪，你们俩，不，不，不，这可能才是重点。你不讨厌那种去餐厅看到一对恩爱情侣，他们坐在卡座的同一边，而不是面对面坐着吗？他们决定屁股挨着屁股坐在同一边，望着餐厅，让所有人都看到他们有多他妈相爱。嘿，杰森，你知道吗？
Do you know how much Amanda would give for you to sit next to at a restaurant for once? Forget it, it's not happening. I'll read you the text. You know I didn't even dance with her at our wedding, you know? Excellent. Is that true? That's how allergic I am to dancing. I'm a serious non-dancer.
你知道阿曼达有多希望能让你在餐厅里坐在她旁边哪怕一次吗？算了吧，不可能的。我读给你听。你知道我在婚礼上甚至都没有跟她跳过舞，你知道吗？太棒了。这是真的吗？这就是我对跳舞的过敏程度。我是个坚决不跳舞的人。
Well, then all I want to ever see you do is dance now. No, I'll have to start drinking again for that. You're not allergic to, no, it's just, that's ego, man. I mean, if we're going to strip it away, that's just all ego, and Phil and Chris want to talk, we all want to talk to you about. This is an honor. Yes, we were here. What's happening?
好吧，那我唯一想看你做的事就是现在跳舞。不，我得为了这个重新开始喝酒。你不是对……不，这只是，这是自负，伙计。我的意思是，如果我们把这些剥离掉，这纯粹就是自负，菲尔和克里斯想谈谈，我们所有人都想和你谈谈。这是一种荣幸。是的，我们在这里。发生什么了？
I think, Phil, did I meet you once before at a, no, no, actually. At like, McShelley's or something. No, no, at, no, no, it was Marino's. And Marino's, that's right, which is right near our Lego offices. That was like our special treat, is they would let us out and let us walk three blocks in the air. Yeah, it was so, you were so nice to come up with. What happens at Marino's?
我觉得，菲尔，我是不是曾在某个地方见过你一次，不，不，其实没有。在类似麦谢利餐厅或什么地方。不，不，在，不，不，是在马里诺餐厅。在马里诺餐厅，没错，就在我们乐高办公室附近。那是我们的特殊款待，他们会放我们出来，让我们在空气中走三个街区。 yeah, 它太了，你能来真是太好了。马里诺餐厅有什么？
Caesar salad. Is that still there? Marino's is great on Melrose. It's great, yeah. On Melrose, yeah. It's super old school, very fun, like kind of like red booths, Italian restaurant. Oh, and they make, they mix a Caesar in front of you?
凯撒沙拉。那个还在吗？梅尔罗斯大街上的马里诺餐厅很棒。很棒，是的。在梅尔罗斯大街上，是的。它是超级老派的，非常有趣，有点像红色的卡座，意大利餐厅。哦，他们会做，他们会在你面前拌凯撒沙拉吗？
One of those. They mix a Caesar in front of you, a Mexican dish. They really do, and then the guy will come out every once in a while and go like, hey, listen, it's not a Mexican dish. No, but he'll come out and he'll go, he'll go up. The guy will come out and he'll go, listen, now it's not on the menu, but I'm gonna let you know we've got a nice fresh brazol that we just made,
那种。他们会在你面前拌凯撒沙拉，一道墨西哥菜。他们真的会，然后那家伙会时不时地出来说，嘿，听着，这不是一道墨西哥菜。不，但他会出来然后说，他会走过来。那家伙会出来然后说，听着，现在这不在菜单上，但我得告诉你们，我们刚做了一份非常新鲜的布拉佐尔，
a beautiful brazol. For real, right, Sean? And they'll bring it to you. I was there with Jimmy Valoli years ago, and the guy's like, we've got this fresh brazol. I don't tell anybody. Like it's a state fucking secret. That's so true.
一份漂亮的布拉佐尔。对吧，肖恩？他们会把它端给你。多年前我和吉米·瓦洛利一起去那里，那家伙就像是，我们有这种新鲜的布拉佐尔。我可不告诉任何人。就像它是什么国家机密一样。太真实了。
Brazol, I'm gonna hit socials on this one. Now wait, Phil and Chris, so Jason, he mentioned, so would you rather be in a room, arms linked on a keyboard. Talk to us about how, this is how you guys started. I mean, that's what you guys, you still do, but that's how you guys started writing together. What was, how did that happen? Where did you meet?
布拉佐尔，我要在社交媒体上发这个。现在等等，菲尔和克里斯，所以杰森，他提到了，所以你们愿意在一个房间里，手臂搭在键盘上吗。跟我们聊聊这是怎么回事，这是你们开始的方式。我的意思是，这就是你们，你们现在还在这样做，但这就是你们开始合作写作的方式。那是怎样的，那是怎么发生的？你们是在哪里认识的？
Yeah, how did you guys start writing together? We met in college, freshman week, somebody said, oh, I know someone just as weird as you. What school? I had Dartmouth College in Hanover, New Hampshire. Beautiful, beautiful time. We, Phil convinced me to take an animation class, and we started making student films,
是的，你们是怎么开始一起写作的？我们在大学认识的，大一那周，有人说，哦，我认识一个和你一样怪的人。哪所学校？我是新罕布什尔州汉诺威的达特茅斯学院。美好，美好的时光。我们，菲尔说服我去上了一门动画课，然后我们开始制作学生电影，
and somehow got our way making Saturday morning cartoons back when that was a thing that still existed. Sounds like you guys were crushing a lot of ass in college. Oh my God, let me tell you. Talk us through some of that. Oh man, I tell you, the ladies love a couple of cartoonists doodling away in a studio. Oh, I so wish I could do that.
不知怎么的，在周六早上的卡通片还存在的那个年代，我们找到了一条制作周六早晨卡通片的路。听起来你们在大学里泡了不少妞。哦，天哪，我跟你讲。跟我们讲讲其中的一些。哦，天哪，我告诉你，女士们可喜欢两个在工作室里涂鸦的动画师了。哦，我多么希望我也能那样。
Are you guys almost done with that pen? Just the risk control. Yeah, yeah. Now, do you guys didn't, did you go to school for that, or did you guys have a plan? I was a government major, so I mean, it was, it was sort of a thing we were doing on the side is making films and stuff like that.
你们快用完那支笔了吗？只是风险控制。 yeah, yeah. 现在，你们没有，你们是去学校专门学这个的吗，还是你们有什么计划？我是政府学专业的，所以我的意思是，这，这算是我们在副业上做的事情，比如拍电影之类。
What's the difference in a government major and a political science major? It's the same thing, that's what they called it there, because they have to be weird. Oh, all right. Right, just to be different. Are you still really into politics? Not that we're going to get into politics, which is curious.
政府学专业和政治学专业有什么区别？是一回事，他们在那儿就这么叫，因为他们必须显得古怪。哦，好吧。对吧，就是为了与众不同。你们现在还是很热衷政治吗？并不是说我们要涉足政治，这挺奇怪的。
I am, I am still into politics. It's very infuriating. And do you enjoy sort of like trying to trojan horse in some political sort of messages maybe in some of your stuff? Don't answer that. Don't answer that. Protect your business.
我是，我还是很热衷政治。这非常气人。你们喜欢在你们的一些作品中暗度陈仓地加入一些政治信息吗？别回答这个。别回答这个。保护你们的生意。
Protect your business. Blink, just blink. I think everything is political in the world. That's right. That's right. What an outrageous statement. I tell you what. So when you guys first started making shows and stuff,
保护你们的生意。眨眼，眨眼就行。我认为世界上的万物皆政治。没错。没错。多么惊世骇俗的声明。我跟你说。所以当你们刚开始制作节目之类的时候，
how did you know you clicked just the same sense of humor in the same sense of kind of like what's the thing where you're like, oh god, this guy's funny or cool? When we were in college, when we met each other, we were like, we felt like kindred spirits. We both loved, you know, Harold and Maude and Steve Martin movies and all this other stuff. And we all just had like the same.
你们是怎么知道你们一拍即合，有着相同的幽默感，并且对诸如“哦天哪，这家伙真搞笑或真酷”之类的事情有共鸣的？我们在大学里，当我们遇到彼此的时候，我们就像是，我们觉得自己是灵魂伴侣。我们俩都喜欢，你知道的，比如《哈罗德和莫德》和史蒂夫·马丁的电影以及所有这些其他东西。我们大家都有着同样的。
And there was no fox affiliate in Hanover. So Chris's sister would mail VHS tapes of The Simpsons. I worked with Chris's sister. That's right. You did. Oh, really? She says, would you please tell her hi. Time out.
而且汉诺威没有福克斯的分支机构。所以克里斯的姐姐会寄来《辛普森一家》的VHS录像带。我和克里斯的姐姐共事过。没错。你做过。哦，真的吗？她说，请代她向她问好。暂停。
Time out what? Yeah, yeah. She worked with us at aggregate back in the Universal Days. It's true. Oh, I thought you were going to say she worked on that ice capade special you did with Alyssa Milano that Kimmel sent us the other day. She read for it.
暂停什么？对，对。她在环球影城时期的Aggregate和我们一起工作过。真的吗？哦，我还以为你要说她参与了吉米·梅尔顿前几天寄给我们的那个由爱莉萨·米兰诺主演的冰上滑冰特辑呢。她试镜了。
She got pretty close. We had her back a few times. Don't worry. I'll send it to all you guys who Kimmel sent it to us the other day. No, we had a real heavy sweater on. Now, how do you? Now, listen, you guys are jokingly saying
她差一点就选上了。别担心。我会把它发给你们所有人，吉米前几天寄给我们的。不，我们当时穿着一件很重的毛衣。现在，怎么样？现在，听着，你们在开玩笑地说，
that you were weird in college. And I was pretty weird at that age as well. As I think we all were. Anybody was. We all go through our awkward periods. And we all think we're kind of funny. And we've got like this odd sense of humor. But there's a big, big spread between that
你们在大学时很古怪。我在那个年纪也挺古怪的。我想我们所有人都是。任何人都是。我们都会经历我们的尴尬期。我们都觉得自己挺有趣的。而且我们有一种奇怪的幽默感。但这之间有很大、很大的差距，
and actually being able to like make it and use that in a way that actually brings success and futures. And how did you guys get from being kind of awkward, funny, smart guys at Dartmouth to being up there on top of the mountain? I mean, I'm sure it's a long answer, not longer than the question. But let's hear it. Oh, what a fucking journey. I just had to go put my winter clothing in the basement.
与真正能够做到这一点并在实际上带来成功和未来的方式中使用它之间。你们是怎么从达特茅斯那种尴尬、搞笑、聪明的家伙，变成站在山顶上的呢？我的意思是，我确信这是一个很长的答案，不过不会比问题还长。但让我们听听吧。哦，真是一段他妈的旅程。我刚才不得不把我的冬装放到地下室。
Winter Vegas and won a few slots and came back. You assholes. Guys. Well, go ahead. Irrational confidence. Yeah, I think that was. Yeah, we were in San Francisco. I was doing an internship at ILM.
冬季拉斯维加斯，赢了几台老虎机然后回来了。你们这群混蛋。伙计们。好吧，继续。不理性的自信。是的，我想那是。是的，我们在旧金山。我在ILM实习。
And Phil came to visit me. And we took a hike to Coyt Tower and looked out over San Francisco famous for beautiful movie making or maybe it was the wrong city, but it was the right state. And we were like, let's go try to make it in Hollywood. And we decided then there. You had an actual moment. First of all, Sean, tell Tracy what ILM is.
然后菲尔来看我。我们徒步去了科伊特塔，俯瞰以制作精美电影闻名的旧金山，或者也许那是错误的城市，但那是正确的州。然后我们说，让我们去好莱坞闯闯。我们就在那时当机立断。你们经历了一个真正的时刻。首先，肖恩，告诉特雷西什么是ILM。
Oh, yes. It's the Industrial Light Magic, which was George Lucas. Is George Lucas coming? Was George Lucas' company? And they do all the special effects for all the movies and of all time. Right. So you guys are up there and you're like,
哦，是的。那是工业光魔，也就是乔治·卢卡斯的。乔治·卢卡斯要来吗？是乔治·卢卡斯的公司吗？他们为所有电影制作所有的特效。没错。所以你们站在那里，你们就像是，
you have this moment. You're inspired and you guys are looking out and the sun is. Yes, we had like a movie moment. It was very romantic, even. But at that point, you guys had been working on, you had made some cartoons. Yeah, I want to know that. What were those first cartoons?
你们有了这个时刻。你们受到了启发，你们俯瞰着阳光。是的，我们有过电影般的时刻。甚至非常浪漫。但当时，你们一直在致力于，你们制作了一些动画片。是的，我想知道那个。那些早期的动画片是什么？
We made, in my dorm room, we made two short films that we hand animated. One was like a self-portrait that I did called Self Mambo. Yeah, it's just fine. And then Chris's was called Sleazy Goes to Hell. Yes. And then I had a character named Sleazy, the wonder squirrel, who was in the comic strip I did for The Daily Paper.
我们在我的宿舍里制作了两部手绘短片。其中一部是我做的自画像，叫做《自我曼波》。是的，这很好。然后克里斯的那部叫做《色情狂下地狱》。是的。然后我有一个角色叫色情狂，奇迹松鼠，他出现在我为《每日报》画的连环漫画里。
It was this really sophisticated humor. We were the only people in the class who liked jokes. So these are sketched now. Is it like a flip book? Is that how you kind of like did the film? Yeah, you shoot it on. We shot it on a 16 millimeter camera, frame by frame. And then it was the olden days.
这是那种真正的精致幽默。我们是班上唯二喜欢笑话的人。所以这些现在都是草图吗？就像翻页书一样？这就是你们制作电影的方式吗？是的，你用它拍摄。我们用16毫米摄像机一帧一帧地拍摄。那是旧时光。
It was a bolex that was just pointed at the floor with duct tape on the legs and a thing with jam. And you do one little sketch that moves the hand a little bit more and then another piece of paper. Very tedious. And thankfully, you never have to do that again. But yeah, but here's the thing. So you guys do that.
那是一台博莱克斯摄像机，只是对着地板，腿上贴着胶带，还有一个带果酱的东西。然后你做一个小草图，让手多动一点，再放一张纸。非常乏味。谢天谢地，你再也不用做那个了。但是，但是事情是这样的。所以你们做了那个。
You quite literally start in the most basic form of animation. You guys are just doing it literally by the numbers. Earning it. Earning it all the way through. Then you guys go and you do a bunch of series and you do Clone High. You do all these great things. And then you do Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs,
你们简直是从最基础的动画形式开始。你们真的就是一步一个脚印地做。一点点挣来的。一路挣来的。然后你们去做了很多剧集，你们做了《克隆高校》。你们做了所有这些伟大的事情。然后你们做了《天降美食》，
which we'll get to in a second. Right. And just for a trade, just since you're doing that well for Tracy, it's Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs, the Lego movie, 22 Jump Street, right? Yeah. So what I was going to get to is, and kind of what Jason said, like when did you guys know that you were cool
我们一会儿会谈到。对。为了给特雷西做个盘点，既然你们做得那么好，《天降美食》、《乐高大电影》、《龙虎少年队2》，对吧？是的。所以我要说的是，就像杰森说的，你们什么时候知道自己很酷，
and kind of shed all that stuff? It's almost like what I realized was did you guys, did our appetites or people's appetites for what you guys do change? Or did you guys change the appetites by the stuff that you guys were doing? I feel like you guys have been really consistent in what you do.
并且甩掉了所有那些标签？我意识到的是，你们，我们的胃口或者人们对你们所做事情的胃口变了吗？还是你们通过你们正在做的事情改变了人们的胃口？我觉得你们在做的事情上一直非常一致。
And it's taken a while for people to catch up with, hey, these guys are doing something really cool. Yeah, I mean, we were super ahead of our time. Way ahead of our time. Visionaries. We're actually talking to them in the future right now. I know that you'll never say that about yourself, but I think that you guys are.
花了一段时间人们才赶上，嘿，这些家伙在做一些真正酷的事情。是的，我的意思是，我们大大超前于我们的时代。远远超前于我们的时代。有远见的人。我们现在实际上是在和未来的他们对话。我知道你永远不会那样评价自己，但我认为你们就是。
I've known you guys for a long time. I think that's totally fair, yeah. I mean, we spent eight years working on sitcoms before we really ever got to make our own thing. And so we got to learn a lot from a lot of great people. We got better, I think. I mean, if you look at our student films, they're very bad. They have moments.
我认识你们很久了。我认为这完全公平，是的。我的意思是，在我们真正有机会制作自己的东西之前，我们花了八年时间制作情景喜剧。所以我们从很多伟大的人身上学到了很多。我想我们变好了。我的意思是，如果你看我们的学生电影，它们真的很烂。它们有高光时刻。
Yeah. But I think that the thing that we always had was we didn't want to do something that had ever been done before. And so we were always trying to figure out, how do we do something new? How would we do something that I haven't seen a million times before?
是的。但我认为我们一直拥有的东西是，我们不想做以前从来没有做过的事情。所以我们一直在想，我们如何做一些新的东西？我怎么能做一些我没有看过一百万次的东西？
Because there's so much crap out there. It's you need to find a way to differentiate yourself. You're just making something to make it. It's boring. But when did you guys notice that you had been embraced either by the community or the public, or maybe both, such that you knew that your humor would be accepted?
因为外面有太多的垃圾。你需要找到一种让自己脱颖而出的方法。你只是为了做而做。这很无聊。但你们是什么时候注意到自己已经被社群或公众所接纳，或者两者兼而有之，以至于你们知道你们的幽默会被接受的？
Yeah, because it's like, oh, it's a Lord Miller thing. So anything that feels subversive, or I feel like I should be laughing, but I'm not yet. And the audience felt like, well, I just need to catch up. I need to be a little bit smarter. Sort of like, it's like the Radiohead thing, right? Like, Jesus, I cannot tap my toe to this song, but I know it's my fault.
是的，因为这就像是，哦，这是一个洛德米勒风格的东西。所以任何感觉颠覆性的东西，或者我觉得我应该笑，但我还没笑。观众觉得，嗯，我只是需要赶上。我需要变得更聪明一点。有点像，这就像电台司令乐队的效应，对吧？就像，天哪，我无法随着这首歌打节拍，但我知道这是我的错。
And I got to get with it. I listened to OK Computer one more time. I mean, that's where you guys sit. Thank you, I guess. That's very generous. I think we're just sort of like too blockheaded to change. I just think it's awesome. There's a brand there, you know, that people just like,
我得振作起来。我把《OK电脑》又听了一遍。我的意思是，这就是你们坐的位置。谢谢，我想是的。这太慷慨了。我想我们只是有点太顽固而不知变通。我只是觉得这太棒了。那里有一个品牌，你知道，人们只是觉得，
oh my god, their humor is super duper smart, and it is something different. And it takes a long time for me to get it, because it must be funny, because it doesn't seem like it's funny right now. It's your fault if you're not laughing. That's what we want the audience to say. We'll be right back. And now, back to the show.
哦，天哪，他们的幽默超级聪明，而且它确实是与众不同的。我需要很长时间才能理解，因为它一定很有趣，因为现在看起来好像不太好笑。如果你没有笑，那是你的错。这就是我们希望观众说的话。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目中。
So you guys worked on sitcoms. You guys were, and tell the audience what shows you guys worked on. Well, not to brag. Primarily. There was a Louis Guzman sitcom called Louis. Yeah. But we actually, the one that anyone remembers
所以你们做过情景喜剧。你们是，并且告诉观众你们做过哪些节目。好吧，不是吹牛。主要是。有一个路易斯·古兹曼的情景喜剧叫《路易》。是的。但实际上，我们做过的、任何人都记得的那个
is How I Met Your Mother, which we did. We worked on the first season of. Right. So you guys worked on that show. And I would say, again, would you think that that experience of working on a show like that with a big writer's room, did that help you hone how you told jokes in movies?
是《老爸老妈的浪漫史》，我们制作了第一季。没错。所以你们做过那个节目。我想说，再次强调，你们认为在这样一个拥有宏大编剧室的节目中工作的经历，是否有助于你们磨练在电影中讲笑话的方式？
Because I love those writing room experiences. They're great. And they teach you so much. You get so many at-bats in a room full of funny people. You get to absorb a bunch of different points of view on writing and comedy. You have this amazing safety net where you could try things out and people help you save you from your worst instincts.
因为我喜欢那些编剧室的经历。它们太棒了。它们教会你很多东西。你在一个充满有趣之人的房间里得到了这么多的击球机会。你可以吸收关于写作和喜剧的许多不同观点。你拥有一个令人惊叹的安全网，在那里你可以尝试各种事情，人们会帮你摆脱最糟糕的本能。
And then it's so collaborative. And that's the part that really helps you when you're making movies, is that there's a class of filmmaker that's like a genius that you should not mess with. And they just like, it comes to them from Zeus. And then they put it on the page and on the screen. And that is not us.
而且它是如此具有合作性。这正是你在拍电影时真正能帮到你的部分，有一类电影人就像是个天才，你绝不能去干涉他们。他们只是，灵感从宙斯那里降临到他们身上。然后他们把它写在纸上和屏幕上。而那不是我们。
Our thing is much more like, let's find it, let's make mistakes, and especially in an animated film. But on any movie, you're getting the benefit of all these smart filmmakers that are part of the crew and part of the cast. And that experience in those writer's rooms really helped us. And it's allowed us to be flexible and be open to ideas
我们的风格更像是，让我们去寻找，让我们犯错，尤其是在动画电影中。但在任何电影中，你都在受益于作为剧组和演员阵容一部分的所有这些聪明的电影人。在那些编剧室里的经历真正帮助了我们。它让我们变得灵活，并对来自
from everyone. And part of the thing is to get a great cast of people who can also provide stuff, working with Will was awesome because he was able to, I mean, yeah. Well, you know, it's a good ending, but I was talking about Will Forte and Will Farrell. Oh, right, yes, Forte, fantastic, and Farrell. They both give you a lot of options.
所有人的想法保持开放。其中的一部分是挑选一群伟大的演员，他们也能提供很多东西，和威尔合作太棒了，因为他能够，我的意思是，是的。好吧，你知道，这是一个很好的结尾，但我在说的是威尔·福特和威尔·法瑞尔。哦，对了，是的，福特，太棒了，还有法瑞尔。他们俩都给你提供了很多选择。
And then we just did this show, the after party, where it's just full of a bunch of funny people. And they all were able to bring a lot of stuff. And that openness that you learn in the writer's room to following the best idea was a great training ground. I think the other thing that really helps you is that you're also trained to listen for the audience and whether they are laughing or engaged.
然后我们刚刚制作了这部剧，浮华宴，里面到处都是有趣的人。他们都带来了很多东西。你在编剧室里学到的那种追随最佳创意的开放心态是一个很好的训练场。我认为真正能帮助你的另一件事是，你还接受过训练，去倾听观众的反应，看他们是在笑还是被吸引。
And that ethic is really important to our filmmaking process, just understanding what it's like to sit in a theater and experience people's vibe while they watch it and respecting that enough to go, OK, it's not that these 500 people are dumb. It's that we failed to convey our idea. Right, and to give and to leave room for them to appreciate it, too, in that way,
这种职业道德对我们的电影制作过程非常重要，只需理解坐在影院里体验观众在观看时的氛围是什么样的，并对此给予足够的尊重，说，好吧，并不是这500个人很笨。而是我们没能传达我们的想法。没错，并且给予并留出空间让他们也能以那种方式去欣赏，
that there is a kind of a rhythm between you and the audience, that it is a show, that you're not making the jokes to make yourselves laugh. You're making it to be funny and to be entertainment. And they have to be able to have the room to enjoy it and engage. You talked about all these people. You guys are such great collaborators.
你们和观众之间存在着一种节奏，这是一个节目，你们制作笑话不是为了让自己发笑。你们是为了搞笑和娱乐。他们必须能够有空间去享受和投入。你们谈到了所有这些人。你们真是太棒的合作者了。
Not only are you a collaborative team yourselves, but you guys have collaborated with a lot of people over the years, multiple times. For example, I'm one of the few people who have seen the great pilot, I think, that you did with the Lonely Island Boys before they did that sonnet called Awesome Town, which was so funny. And I remember thinking, like, what the fuck is this?
你们不仅是一个合作团队，而且多年来你们还与许多人多次合作。例如，我是少数看过那个伟大的试播集的人之一，我想，那是你们在“孤独岛”男孩们创作那首名为《真棒小镇》的十四行诗之前制作的，太搞笑了。我记得当时想，这他妈是什么？
And who are these guys? It was so crazy. Now, of course, it wasn't going to get picked up, because it was way too insane. But we held the grudge about them not picking it up for quite some time. So we made that thing. We tried to sell it to Fox.
这些家伙是谁？太疯狂了。当然，它不会被选中，因为它太疯狂了。但我们对他们没有选中它这件事怀恨在心了好一阵子。所以我们制作了那个东西。我们试图把它卖给福克斯。
And then MTV, nobody wanted it. And then suddenly, five months later, Lazy Sunday happened. Giant sensations. And Andy was hosting the MTV Movie Awards. Andy Samberg, yeah. Yeah. And Phil kept texting all of the MTV execs who
然后是MTV，没有人想要它。然后突然之间，五个月后，“懒惰星期天”发生了。巨大的轰动。安迪当时在主持MTV电影大奖。安迪·萨姆堡，是的。是的。而菲尔一直在给所有那些
passed on the show, going like, whoops. Here is a 50-foot tall billboard of Andy on a Hollywood in Highland. The one that got away. It was so, yeah. I was just thinking, like, these guys are, once again, ahead of the curve. You guys worked with Forte so many times over the years
拒绝了这部剧的MTV高管发短信，内容像是，哎呀。这是安迪在好莱坞和海兰德大街上的50英尺高的巨型广告牌。那个错过的机会。太，是的。我当时只是在想，这些家伙，又一次走在了时代前沿。这些年来，你们和福特合作过很多次，
on lots of different projects. It's somebody who we all know. And it took a while for America to go like, but you guys were like, well, Forte's the funniest fucking guy ever. Yeah. And then you're proved right. Again, yes, we all know it.
在许多不同的项目上。这是一个我们都知道的人。美国花了好一阵子才开始说，但你们当时就觉得，威尔·福特是他妈的最好笑的家伙。是的。然后你们被证明是正确的。是的，我们都知道。
Do you guys, in order for your sensibilities to line up, did you find out, as you guys were getting to know each other in college, that you had similar upbringings? We really did, actually. We both were really short in high school and grew late. And so we had, we both had, like, a very similar upbringing weirdly.
为了让你们的艺术敏感度契合，你们是否在大学里逐渐了解彼此的过程中发现，你们有相似的成长经历？我们确实有，真的。我们俩在高中时都很矮，而且发育得很晚。所以我们俩，奇怪的是，都有着非常相似的成长经历。
We can't relate to winners. That's right. We always feel like the little pipsqueak in the corner. OK. I'm sorry to break it to you, but don't look now. You do both seem to, like, I can't imagine you guys ever getting in an argument. What is the one area where you guys go, oh, let's not talk
我们无法与赢家共情。没错。我们总是觉得自己是角落里的小不点。好吧。我很抱歉打破你的幻想，但别看现在。你们俩看起来确实，我无法想象你们会争吵。你们俩异口同声说“哦，我们别谈这个了”的领域是什么？
about it? Here's the biggest fight we ever had. Yes. The biggest fight we ever had is over the shape of Abraham Lincoln's nose. On the show, Clone High. Clone High. This is Will Forte's character.
这是我们经历过的最大争吵。是的。我们经历过的最大争吵是关于亚伯拉罕·林肯鼻子的形状。在节目《克隆高校》中。克隆高校。这是威尔·福特的角色。
We got him a side card to voice because we thought he was a funny guy. Forte was a very funny writer at that time, and had we had seen him at the Aspen Comedy Festival, where he did a sketch where they just said the phrase, ain't no party like an Otis Day party because an Otis Day party don't quit for 10 minutes with different questions, which was brilliant.
我们让他客串配音，因为我们觉得他是个有趣的人。福特在那个时期是一个非常有趣的作家，我们曾在阿斯彭喜剧节上见过他，他在那里表演了一个小品，他们只是把“没有派对像奥蒂斯·戴的派对，因为奥蒂斯·戴的派对一连10分钟停不下来，有着各种各样的问题”这句话说了一遍又一遍，这太绝妙了。
And the most Forte type of film. The most Forte idea of all time. So important. And he was still, I think he was doing groundlings and did the gold man sketch. But the gold man is the greatest sketch. Well, so what's the gold man's sketch? The gold man's sketch.
最具有福特风格的电影。有史以来最具有福特特色的想法。太重要了。而且他当时还在，我想他当时在The Groundlings剧团，还表演了金人小品。但金人小品是最棒的小品。好吧，那么金人小品是什么？金人小品。
Can you guys describe it? It's really not family friendly. It's not a super family friendly thing. So he's on stage. He's in full gold makeup. Like he's one of those robot men, the street performers. And they have to do this sketch. This has to be the last sketch of the night for two reasons.
你们能描述一下吗？它真的不是老少咸宜的。它不是一个非常适合全家观看的东西。所以他在舞台上。他画着全身金色妆容。就像他是那些机器人人之一，街头艺人。他们必须表演这个小品。这必须是当晚的最后一个小品，出于两个原因。
One is that the gold paint takes hours to get off. And the other is, well, you'll see, is that someone puts a dollar on his thing and he starts singing this song called Heart of Gold, where he's explaining about his life. And then it ends up devolving into this thing about how he sucks cock for his face paint. And then it just becomes, he just keeps going,
一个是金色的油漆需要几个小时才能洗掉。另一个是，嗯，你们会看到的，有人把一美元放在他的盘子里，他开始唱一首叫《金心》的歌，他在歌里解释他的生活。然后它最终演变成一桩关于他为了脸上的颜料去吹箫的事。然后就变成，他一直说，
I'll suck cock for my face paint. That's a lot of the work at times. And what happens is the room starts to clear. Because it goes for also like 10 minutes. It goes forever. And people just decide they're going to leave. Worst case scenario is they're going to miss maybe the last sketch or the last two sketches.
我为了脸上的颜料去吹箫。这有时需要做很多工作。结果是房间开始清空。因为这也持续了大约10分钟。它没完没了。人们只是决定离开。最坏的情况是他们可能会错过最后一个小品或最后两个小品。
So that's why they had to put it at the end. It's one of the crazy, funniest fucking things you've ever seen because it comes out of nowhere. Because at first he's, if I remember correctly, in the schedule at different times, but he'll get kind of, the guy puts a dollar in. I saw him do it with Sudeika's once when they did that never aired live SNL at UCB
这就是为什么他们必须把它放在最后。这是你见过的最疯狂、最好笑的他妈的事情之一，因为它是凭空出现的。因为一开始他，如果我没记错的话，在时间表里的不同时间，但他会变得有点，那家伙投了一块钱。我记得有一次在作家罢工期间，他们在UCB表演那个从未直播的SNL时，我看到他演过……
during the writer strike and whatever. And he's like puts a thing in, he's trying to get him in the mood. And then he finally starts, and then he just does it too. And he's not even doing the characters. He's doing it to the audience. I suck cock for my face paint. And he just breaks him that shit.
当时有人投了一块钱，他正试图让他进入状态。然后他终于开始了，然后他也这么做了。他甚至都没有在演角色。他是对着观众说的。我为了脸上的颜料去吹箫。他直接把那帮人弄崩溃了。
I love that the character is so like, just hearing that for the first time, I'm thinking how important that face paint is to that character that would do anything to obtain it. Of course it's incredible. And it's so forte. Now look, I know that you guys don't fight, but we've never fought,
我喜欢那个角色如此……只是第一次听到这个，我在想面部彩妆对那个会不惜一切代价去获得它的角色来说有多么重要。当然这太不可思议了。而且太有福特的风格了。现在听着，我知道你们不吵架，但我们从没吵过，
but we have to bring it up because I don't know if these guys know. Let's talk about the time that you guys fired me. Oh boy. Is that true? It is true. We did have to- Talk slow.
但我们必须提一下，因为我不知道这些家伙知不知道。我们来聊聊你们俩把我炒了的那次吧。哦，天哪。这是真的吗？是真的。我们确实不得不——说慢点。
Yeah. Let's hear it. Jason really wants to save right now. We had cast Will for the lead in Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs. It's true. Well, well. And the studio did not think he was the right voice.
是的。让我们听听。杰森现在真的很想自救。我们曾选定威尔担任《天降美食》的男主角。是真的。好吧，好吧。但制片厂觉得他的声音不太合适。
They thought he was too old. Too sounding. Sounded to that. Thank you, Bill. For the character. Thank you. He sounds, well, now I get this, right? Like, so his voice is so undisciplined.
他们觉得他太老了。声音听起来。听起来像那个。谢谢你，比尔。为了这个角色。谢谢你。他听起来，好吧，我现在明白了，对吧？所以他的声音太不受控制了。
This is why the guy sells trucks that are professional grade. Like, fucking Hater couldn't sell a truck, you know? But Hater could, you know, sell something a little bit more sensible, a little bit more economic. Like- He could sell a funny truck.
这就是为什么这家伙能卖出专业级的卡车。就像，他妈的海特根本卖不出一辆卡车，你知道吗？但海特可以，你知道的，卖点更合理、更经济的东西。比如——他可以卖一辆搞笑的卡车。
So we tried to prove everyone wrong and be like, you don't understand. He's really funny. He's great. He's vulnerable. He's wonderful. He's fantastic. And we tried and they said, no.
所以我们试图向所有人证明他们错了，并说，你们不懂。他真的很有趣。他很棒。他很脆弱。他很美妙。他太棒了。我们试过了，但他们说，不。
I will say that this is 100% on us because we had like a first act screening that went great. And then we put the whole movie together. With our Nets voice. And that's- With Will's voice. Me and Amy. You and Amy.
我要说的是，这100%是我们的责任，因为我们有一个第一幕的试映，反响很好。然后我们把整部电影拼凑在了一起。用奈茨的声音。那是——用威尔的声音。我和艾米。你和艾米。
And we put the whole movie together and it sucked. And the reason the whole movie sucked- That's an animatic. Was because like we were good at making you pay attention for 20 minutes at a time. But when you have a whole movie, if the audience can't really root for the main character and get on board, I don't care how funny it is,
我们把整部电影拼凑在了一起，结果它烂透了。整部电影烂掉的原因——那是一部动态分镜。是因为我们擅长让你在20分钟内保持注意力。但当你有一整部电影时，如果观众真的无法为主角加油并产生共鸣，我才不管它有多搞笑，
they go to sleep. And what was going on is like every five minute sequence was like a really funny sequence unto itself. And then strung together, you're like, what is this about? Why do I like these people? And what am I rooting for? And what's emotional about it?
他们会睡着。当时的情况是，每五分钟的序列本身都是一个非常有趣的序列。然后串联在一起，你会想，这讲的是什么？我为什么喜欢这些人？我在为谁加油？这里面有什么情感？
We're like, doesn't matter, it's real funny. And the audience just wouldn't go there. So, and the studio basically blew the movie to bits. And we're like, start over. I remember where I was, I was on, I remember I was on motor right by Rancho, right by the swimming pool there, just south of the Fox lot when I got the call.
我们当时觉得，没关系，这真的很好笑。但观众就是无法接受。所以，制片厂基本上把这部电影炸得粉碎。然后我们说，从头开始。我记得我在哪里，我在，我记得我在莫托大街，就在兰乔旁边，就在那里的游泳池旁，就在福克斯片场南边一点，当我接到那个电话的时候。
Just looking for lost balls. You know? Just picking up some shag balls. Picking up shag balls from Hillcrest Country Club. And I remember, and I remember why I was on the bag. I was just doing a loop that day. I picked up, and I remember getting the call and Amy was back in New York and I pulled over and I go,
只是在找丢掉的球。你知道吗？只是去捡一些练习球。从希尔克莱斯特乡村俱乐部捡练习球。我记得，我记得我为什么拿着包。那天我只是在做循环。我接起电话，我记得接到电话时艾米还在纽约，我把车停在路边，我说，
well, looks like we both got fired from bloody. What's the chance of being both? Oh, Amy got fired too? Oh, it was a team fire. They fired both of us. Yeah, it was a team fire. It was a whole movie blow up. It was a set time.
好吧，看来我们俩都被血腥的给开除了。这两人同时被开除的几率是多少？哦，艾米也被开除了？哦，这是一次团队开除。他们把我们两个都开除了。是的，是一次团队开除。这是一次全片大洗牌。这是一个固定的时间。
And so then years later, Oh, go finish your story well. So we didn't talk for a long time. That was like the last time you get, these guys were really sweet. And they're like, we're so sorry and that this happening this way. And I was like, okay, cool.
然后多年以后，哦，快把你的故事讲完，威利。所以我们有很长一段时间没说话。那是最后一次你，这些家伙真的很贴心。他们说，我们真的很抱歉，事情会变成这样。我说，好吧，酷。
And like, it's hard not to, no matter what the circumstances, when you get fired, it's hard not to be like, I get it and I get this. And they kept putting, again, very kindly, like it's on us and the movie. And I was like, okay, okay. And it's hard not to like go like, yeah, yeah,
而且无论在什么情况下，当你被解雇时，很难不产生这样的想法：我懂，我懂。他们一直在说，再次强调，非常友善地说是我们的问题和电影的问题。我说，好吧，好吧。而且很难不去想，对，对。
they say that, but it's really me. I'm terrible and I'm the worst. But years later when we were making the Lego movie, we were like, you know who would be perfect for Batman is Will. But then we were like, he may not want to talk to us again. And so then we went to the studio and said, we want to hire Will, but we have a thing.
他们是这么说，但其实就是我。我很糟糕，我是最差劲的。但几年后当我们制作《乐高大电影》时，我们就在想，你知道谁来演蝙蝠侠最合适吗，就是威尔。但接着我们又想，他可能再也不想跟我们说话了。所以我们就去找制片厂说，我们想雇威尔，但我们有个条件。
No matter what, he has to stay this part. No way. We cannot, we cannot fire him no matter what happens. If you fire us, that's fine. You got to keep him on. And every- We had to run it all the way up to Jack Warner. That's right.
无论如何，他必须演这个角色。没门。我们不能，不管发生什么我们都绝不能开除他。如果你想开除我们，那没问题。你们必须留下他。而且每一——我们不得不把这事一路汇报到了杰克·华纳那里。没错。
Yeah, they had to talk about Jack Warner. They got him to sort of nod. We can have Bernie style. They made him nod. Now, when you guys are- Let me just finish that story to say this. So these guys call me up. I remember the time Sharon, my agent at the time,
对，他们不得不去跟杰克·华纳谈。他们让他算是点头同意了。我们可以搞伯尼风格。他们让他点头了。话说当你们——让我先把那个故事讲完，好说明这一点。所以这两个家伙给我打电话。我记得当时我的经纪人莎朗，
she called me. She's like, Phil and Chris want to call you. Don't hang up. And she's like, they have something they want to say to you. And she didn't tip it. And these guys were like, listen. So we're going to do the Lego movie. Do you want to play Batman?
她给我打电话。她说，菲尔和克里斯想给你打电话。别挂电话。她说，他们有话对你说。而且她没有透露风声。然后这两个家伙就说，听着。我们要拍《乐高大电影》了。你想演蝙蝠侠吗？
And I was like, I don't even get that sentence. I don't know what the Lego movie means. Like, what are you talking about? And then they walked me through it. And I remember, this is my recollection of it. So we go, we make the movie. Oh my God. And didn't Michael Sarah play Robin too?
当时我就想，我甚至听不懂这句话。我不知道《乐高大电影》是什么意思。就像，你们在说什么？然后他们把整个概念向我解释了一遍。我记得，这是我的回忆。然后我们去拍了这部电影。哦，天哪。迈克尔·塞拉是不是也给罗宾配音了？
No, that was in Lego Batman, which we made three. We ended up making three movies. And these guys, I remember we go in the first couple of times we're at recording at Warner Brothers. And I've, you know, you do a lot of things where you work on that are really fun, especially in person, they're really fun. Making animated movies can be quite an isolating experience
不，那是《乐高蝙蝠侠大电影》，我们拍了三部。我们最后拍了三部电影。而且这两个家伙，我记得我们前几次去华纳兄弟录音的时候。你知道的，你做过很多很有趣的工作，特别是在现场的时候，真的很有趣。制作动画电影可能会是一段相当孤立的经历
and not that much fun. But these guys were in the booth. Some of the hardest laughs I've ever had in show business were in, in my life, forget show business, we're in the booth with these two guys. We laughed so hard. At one point we were doing this scene about Batman. You guys remember, know what I'm going to talk about?
而且没那么好玩。但这两个家伙就在录音棚里。我在演艺圈经历过的一些最疯狂的大笑，不，说真的，忘掉演艺圈吧，是我这辈子跟这两个家伙在录音棚里度过的。我们笑得太厉害了。有一次我们在拍这场关于蝙蝠侠的戏。你们还记得吗，知道我要说什么吗？
Yeah. About Batman. Tell me what the line was that he said. Was it the thing about he has a, he has like a crippling need to party with other people? With complete strangers. Wait, so it's also, you guys are laughing about stuff
对。关于蝙蝠侠。告诉我他说的台词是什么。是不是关于他有一种，他有一种无法克制的需要，想要和别人一起开派对？跟完全陌生的人。等等，所以也是，你们在笑那些
that you couldn't possibly use in the movie. Is that right? I think we used that part of it. He was trying to explain why he was like, why he abandoned everyone to go party with strangers. And he had a crippling addiction to partying with complete strangers. He was positioning himself as the victim, which was amazing.
你们根本不可能在电影里用的东西。是这样吗？我想我们用了其中的一部分。他当时在试图解释为什么他会，为什么他抛弃了所有人去跟陌生人开派对。他有一种无法克制的、跟完全陌生的人开派对的瘾。他把自己塑造成了受害者，这太棒了。
Was it, it wasn't, it wasn't rated R was it? No. No, no, no, no. But it was adjacent. Was it not? Was it PG-13? No, it was very, it was very PG. Yeah.
那是，它不是，它不是R级片吧？不。不，不，不，不。但它很接近。不是吗？它是PG-13级吗？不，它是非常，它是非常PG级。对。
Oh really? But anyway, so just to tie this up. So I remember, I remember we did that. I had so many amazing times laughing with these guys. And they're just the funniest and all the stuff that they pitched and would say to me in the moment, because there'd be the script and then one of them would be like, say this, say this,
哦，真的吗？但不管怎样，总而言之。所以I我记得，我记得我们做了那个。我和这些家伙一起度过了那么多笑声不断的精彩时光。他们简直是最搞笑的，他们在现场抛出的所有梗，还有对我说的话，因为原本是有剧本的，然后他们其中一个人会说，说这个，说这个，
say this, and we just had so many great, amazing moments. And their brilliance was incredible. And then we go and the movie comes out. And remember that night and these guys go, we go to this, that bar in Santa Monica, we all had dinner. Do you remember? Another,
说这个，我们有那么多精彩绝伦的时刻。他们的才华令人难以置信。然后我们去了，电影上映了。还记得那个夜晚，这些家伙说，我们去圣莫尼卡的那家酒吧，我们一起吃晚饭。你还记得吗？另一家，
Or Vitos. Another, another old school, an empty Italian restaurant. Vitos. Vitos. And the returns start coming in on the movie and it's just doing better and better,
或者维托餐厅。另一家，另一家老字号、空荡荡的意大利餐厅。维托餐厅。维托餐厅。然后这部电影的票房开始出炉了，而且表现越来越好，
like every 15 minutes, they're like, no, wait, it's gonna make this. And then I was like, this is so crazy. And then the guy, and then they say to me, they go, hey, how would you feel if we made Lego, a Lego Batman movie next? And this is like on the night of this total victory. Opening night.
就像每过15分钟，他们就说，不，等等，票房要达到这个数了。然后我就想，这太疯狂了。然后那家伙，然后他们对我说，嘿，如果我们接下来拍一部《乐高蝙蝠侠》大电影，你觉得怎么样？这就像是在这个大获成功的夜晚。首映之夜。
Yeah, opening night. I'm like, yeah, I guess. And they're like, yeah, the studio wants to do it. I was like, are you kidding? And so like, and then I said, and I don't know if you guys remember, I go, I'm really glad that Clarity of the Chance of Meatballs did not work out.
对，首映之夜。我说，好吧，我猜可以吧。然后他们说，对，制片厂想拍。我说，你们开玩笑吧？然后我就说，我不知道你们俩记不记得，我说，我真的很高兴《天降美食》没有成功。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Everything happens for a reason, for sure. It was the best. Now, when you guys write an animated film, you obviously have to wait to have all the animation done. That happens after the voices are recorded. Is it a different process for you guys doing that versus, because you have to rely on,
对，对，对。凡事发生必有因，肯定的。这真是太棒了。话说当你们写一部动画电影时，你们显然得等到所有的动画都做完。那是在录音之后才发生的。对你们来说，这个过程和，因为你们必须依赖——
you guys aren't still doing the animating, right? The animation. Right, no, no, we're not. We have much more talent at ours. So the whole half of the movie, you have to rely on a whole different set of creative contributions, different than what you can sort of control and guide
你们自己不是还在做动画吧？动画。对，不，不，我们没有。我们团队里有更有才华的人。所以整部电影的一半，你必须依赖一整套完全不同的创意贡献，这跟你能在真人的片场上某种程度上控制和引导的东西是不一样的，对吧？对你们来说有多大区别？
on a live set, right? How different is it for you? Yeah, in a funny way, it's the same skill set, which is you're trying to create an environment where everyone you're working with can thrive and bring something of themselves to it. So, you know, it's either in the booth with really talented guys like you,
对，有趣的是，技能其实是一样的，就是你试图创造一个环境，让你合作的每个人都能茁壮成长，并为之贡献出他们自己的一些东西。所以，你知道，要么是在录音棚里和像你这样非常有才华的人一起，
or you're in a sweat box, you know, watching footage with a bunch of animators in a room. And like, each person's worked on a shot for weeks. Yeah. And so you're just talking about like one moment of like Flint Blockwood sipping coffee and trying to figure out what would be the funniest, most interesting way for him to do that.
要么你是在“汗水盒”里，你知道，和一个房间里的一群动画师一起看素材。而且每个人都在一个镜头上花了几个星期。对。所以你们只是在谈论一个镜头，比如小镇晴空喝咖啡的一个瞬间，然后试图弄清楚对他来说，怎样做才是最搞笑、最有趣的方式。
But how do you articulate to an animator how to draw something that matches your sense of humor? Like, you guys are so great with some of your dry humor too. Like, how do you talk to an animator about making the eyes sort of be half-lidded and the characters kind of over it? And like, that seems like a hard thing to be able to manage every frame.
但你们是如何向动画师阐述如何画出符合你们幽默感的东西的呢？比如，你们对一些冷幽默的运用也很棒。比如，你们是怎么跟动画师沟通，让他们把眼睛画成半睁半闭的，然后角色那种“对一切都感到厌烦”的样子？而且，要能在每一帧都掌控好这一点，听起来好像很难。
Yeah, because it seems like you'd have to hire animators who are funny people as well, right? Exactly, you do. And I think that's part of being a good animator is being able to do that. You're doing half the performance, you know. You're listening to the voice and imagining what it might be.
对，因为听起来你们得雇佣本身也很有趣的动画师，对吧？没错，确实如此。我认为这也是成为一个优秀的动画师的一部分。你承担了一半的表演，你知道的。你听着声音，然后想象它可能会是什么样子。
And as a director or producer, you're doing, it's the same thing as working with an actor. It's just in a much slower process. But do you audition those animators? Like, do you look at their stuff and go, oh, that person knows how to draw? You cast the animator to the shot, where you're like, I think this person
作为一个导演或制片人，你在做的事情，其实和跟演员合作是一样的。只是过程要慢得多。但你们会给那些动画师试镜吗？比如，你们会看他们的作品然后说，哦，那个人会画画吗？你会为这个镜头挑选合适的动画师，你会觉得，我觉得这个人
can do a good job on this bit because this thing is really easy and really straightforward or this one is one that like, needs a little subtlety or this one, there's this one person and she's amazing at this type of comedy. Oh, so you hire a team and then you kind of delegate, you do the love scene, you do the action scene, you do the dry humor scene.
能把这个小片段做好，因为这个东西真的很简单、很直接，或者这个需要一点微妙的处理，或者这个，有这么一个人，她特别擅长这种喜剧。哦，所以你们雇佣一个团队，然后你们就进行分工，你来拍爱情戏，你来拍动作戏，你来拍冷幽默戏。
It's shot to shot. So you get like 50, 60 animators and you do the minimum, I mean, these days, you're getting hundreds. Wow. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show. How many times, how many, can you think back now
是按镜头来的。所以你们找50、60个动画师，然后做最少的事情，我是说，现在这个时候，你们找的是几百人。哇。我们马上回来。好的，回到节目中。你们有多少次，有多少次，现在回想起来——
of moments where you've just standing there in front of an animator and you're acting out what you want? Sometimes that definitely happens. On cloudy, where, you know, a lot of stuff now happens in Vancouver, so you're usually working remote. But on cloudy, we were all in a room with, you know, 60 people at a time. And so, yeah, you would stand up and go like,
那些你站在动画师面前，把想要的效果表演出来的时刻？有时确实会发生这种情况。在《天降美食》里，你知道的，现在很多工作都在温哥华完成，所以你通常是远程工作的。但在《天降美食》里，我们所有人都在一个房间里，你知道的，一次有60个人。所以，是的，你会站起来说，
what if he, what if Flint, you know, types like a Muppet, like this and the most people are scratching their heads going, who are these clowns? But every once in a while, like, there'll be one person go like, yeah, I got that, I totally get what you're laying. You also wanna be open to everyone else's ideas. And once, you know, once the team feels like they can pitch something and it'll get into the movie,
如果他，如果小镇晴空，你知道的，像个布偶那样打字，像这样，然后大多数人都会挠着头想，这群小丑是谁？但每隔一段时间，就会有一个人说，好吧，我懂了，我完全明白你的意思。你也希望对其他所有人的想法保持开放。一旦，你知道的，一旦团队觉得他们可以提出一个想法，并且这个想法能放进电影里，
as long as you give them like the direction of the tone and you show them what success looks like, everyone wants to get on board and jump in. And it's just like, you know, having a really talented cast of improvisers that can like, okay, I know what we're going for, I know the tone, I know the vibe. I know if I say this, it's gonna be on the cutting room floor, if I say this, it has a chance of making it
只要你给他们定好基调的方向，并向他们展示成功的标准是什么，每个人都愿意加入进来并大显身手。这就像，你知道的，拥有一支非常有才华的即兴表演演员阵容，他们能够做到，好吧，我知道我们的目标是什么，我知道基调，我知道氛围。我知道如果我说了这个，它就会被剪掉，如果我说了这个，它就有机会进入
into the show. Are you guys a fan of anything, of current animation now? Do you watch those shows? Are you like, I'm in it, I can't watch it. I'm too, it's my life. I come and go, sometimes I can't. I have to only watch like things that we can't possibly make, like a drama, or like a docuseries
影片中。你们俩是任何东西的粉丝吗，比如现在的动画？你们会看那些节目吗？还是会觉得，我身在其中，我没法看？我太，这就是我的生活。我时而看看，有时看不下去。我只能看那些我们绝对不可能拍出来的东西，比如正剧，或者像纪录片系列
or something, but the cool thing about animation these days is there's so much great work happening and it all looks different. And we're in a golden age where people are trying wild stuff. And on the feature side, which is generally a little more conservative, it's starting to get really wild, which is, you know, we feel good about. I find that hard to believe that there's something
之类的，但现在的动画最酷的地方在于，有很多优秀的作品涌现，而且它们看起来各不相同。我们正处于一个黄金时代，人们在尝试各种疯狂的东西。而在真人电影方面，通常要保守一些，现在也开始变得非常疯狂了，你知道的，这让我们感觉很好。我很难相信有什么东西
that you guys can't do, and I know you're being modest, but I mean, you guys shift pretty seamlessly between live action and animation. And certainly, I know it in comedy, and you guys, it's what you do, but you've done it with such great ease. I kind of wonder what, because you guys do like, you do the Jump Street movies, and then you do Lego, and then you do Spider-Verse, and then you do the after party.
是你们拍不出来的，我知道你们是在谦虚，但我的意思是，你们在真人电影和动画之间转换得非常自如。当然，我知道这在喜剧中是这样，而且你们，这就是你们擅长的，但你们表现得如此轻松自如。我有点好奇，因为你们拍了，比如《龙虎少年团》电影，然后是《乐高》，然后是《蜘蛛侠：平行宇宙》，然后是《After Party》。
What are those moments where you guys look at each other and go, all right, it's time to do an animated movie? Or do you have those, or is it just as stuff becomes? How do you decide what to do since you can do so much? There's, I mean, clearly we just never say no. We need to say no a little bit more. And it's all happening at once, and I can't say there's any calculation, or thinking about like
当你们看着对方并说，好了，是时候拍一部动画电影了，那是怎样的时刻？或者你们会有这种感觉，还是说这只是顺其自然？既然你们能做这么多事情，你们是怎么决定接下来要做什么的？我们，我的意思是，显然我们从不拒绝。我们其实应该稍微多拒绝一点。这一切都在同时发生，我不能说这里面有什么计算，或者在考虑
a filmography or a strategy like that. We're literally just going like, oh, we had that idea two years ago, how are we gonna get that up on its feet? Right, you guys had very, even though you met in college, you had different, you're from different parts of the country, obviously. Phil, you grew up in Miami, is that right? True fact.
什么电影作品年表或这样的策略。我们实际上只是在想，哦，我们两年前有过那个想法，我们要怎么把它付诸实践？没错，你们俩虽然是在大学相识的，但你们有不同的，显然你们来自国家的不同地方。菲尔，你在迈阿密长大的，对吗？千真万确。
True fact. Do you still have a connection? Go Marlins, go Heat? Go Dolphins. Oh. Because I grew up, I'm an old fart who grew up before there were Marlins or Heat. You love Dan Greci.
千真万确。你现在还有联系吗？迈阿密马林鱼队加油，迈阿密热火队加油？迈阿密海豚队加油。哦。因为我长大的时候，我是一个老古董，在马林鱼队或热火队成立之前就长大了。你喜欢丹·格雷奇。
I mean, a huge Bob Greci fan. Bob Greci. And then Brian Greci was my locker mate in the seventh grade. Wow. And his son, Brian, is now a broadcaster, but also a quarterback in the league. And was in the seventh grade, I weighed 60 pounds and Brian weighed 200 and was six feet tall.
我是说，我是鲍勃·格雷奇的超级粉丝。鲍勃·格雷奇。然后布莱恩·格雷奇七年级时是我的储物柜邻居。哇。他的儿子布莱恩现在是一名广播员，同时也是联盟里的四分卫。在七年级的时候，我体重60磅，而布莱恩体重200磅，身高六英尺。
Oh my God, the duo Halloween costume options there are exciting. They're really good. Yeah, he wanted me to be a parrot and I was a pirate. Yeah. So you were big Mark late and Mark Dupre fans is what I'm gleaning. The Mark's brothers, my heart was broken
哦，天哪，那里万圣节双人服装的选择一定很令人兴奋。它们真的很好。对，他想让我扮成一只鹦鹉，而我扮成海盗。对。所以你们是马克·莱特和马克·迪普雷的超级粉丝，我从这里推断出来的。马克斯兄弟，我的心碎了
in the one Super Bowl we were in and then losing to the damn Patriots in 85 was horrible. It scarred me for life. It was terrible. Sports. Sports, Chris, do you have a similar affiliation with sports? I do, I'm a sports fan from the great Pacific Northwest.
在我们参加过的那唯一一届超级碗上，然后1985年输给该死的爱国者队真是太糟糕了。这给我留下了终身心理阴影。太可怕了。体育。体育，克里斯，你对体育也有类似的狂热吗？是的，我是来自伟大的太平洋西北地区的体育迷。
So I'm a Mariners, Seahawks, Seattle Super Sonics fan. Haven't been to any Sonic's games recently, but I'm excited to get back to those. And you're excited for the Kraken, obviously, for the big NHL team. Huge. I just couldn't have grown up further away from one another. I know, like the absolute corner corner.
所以我是水手队、海鹰队、西雅图超音速队的粉丝。最近没有去看过超音速队的比赛，但我很高兴能重新去看。而且你显然为海怪队，为这支伟大的NHL球队感到兴奋。极度兴奋。我俩成长的地方不可能再离得更远了。我知道，就像绝对是西南角和东北角。
It's the diagonal. Yeah. It's either San Diego and Maine would be. That's right. But both port cities. That's right, see. With a significant illicit drug trade. Sure, sure.
这是对角线。对。也就是圣迭戈和缅因州那种感觉。没错。但都是港口城市。没错，你看。而且有着规模可观的非法药物交易。当然，当然。
Yeah, I'm just trying to think, well, first of all, yeah, that's true, but Miami obviously has got Miami Vice, which was pretty great. What's the biggest? We had grunge music when I was there. Grunge music. Yeah, you guys had the killing. Yeah, we invented overpriced coffee while I was there.
是的，我在想，首先，是的，这没错，但迈阿密显然有《迈阿密风云》，那相当棒。最大的亮点是什么？我那会儿有垃圾摇滚（Grunge music）。垃圾摇滚。是的，你们有谋杀案。是的，我在那儿的时候我们发明了价格过高的咖啡。
You guys had Miami Vice and Chris, you had Northern Exposure, so that's good. There you go, there you go. That's right. Chris, how old are your kids, Chris? They're 13 and nine. Boy, girl. They're exactly one of each.
你们有《迈阿密风云》，而克里斯，你有《极地求生》，所以那挺好的。这不就对了嘛。没错。克里斯，你的孩子们多大了，克里斯？他们13岁和9岁。男孩，女孩。他们正好一个男孩一个女孩。
Yeah. Some pepper, match set. Do they like the movies? They like the movies. That you guys make? Yeah, no, it's a thing. I mean, they haven't seen the Jump Street movies yet, although, you know, they're getting close to the gate, yeah.
对。完美的一对。他们喜欢这些电影吗？他们喜欢这些电影。你们拍的？对，不，这很有趣。我的意思是，他们还没看过《龙虎少年团》电影，不过，你知道的，他们快到那个年纪了，对。
And, but they do, they like the movies that we make, and they give notes. They're like, act two is a little slow. Can you guys do another one of those? Can you direct another? Yeah, direct another comedy movie. For some reason, it's just so freaking great. They've got the After Party, which has been-
而且，但他们确实喜欢我们拍的电影，而且他们会提意见。他们会说，第二幕有点慢。你们能再拍一部那种类型的吗？你们能再导演一部吗？对，再导演一部喜剧电影。不知为什么，这真的太棒了。他们拍了《After Party》，这部剧——
They've got the After Party on Apple TV Plus. Oh, gotcha. It's a live action murder mystery comedy. Thanks a lot for making Murderville right around the same time, Will, that was really helpful. Sorry. Would you guys ever go back to your traditional kind of beginning and do a multi-cam traditional sitcom?
他们在Apple TV Plus上推出了《After Party》。哦，明白了。这是一部真人谋杀悬疑喜剧。威尔，非常感谢你差不多在同一时间制作了《谋杀之城》，这真的很有帮助。抱歉。你们会考虑重回你们传统的起点，拍一部多机位的传统情景喜剧吗？
Like a classic sitcom? Yeah, would you ever do that? Yeah, I mean, if the right one was there- What if the wrong one was there? The wrong one? Could you make it right? Probably, we could do that as well. Sean's got something he's gonna send you.
就像经典情景喜剧那样？对，你们会拍那种吗？对，我的意思是，如果有合适的剧本的话——如果遇到不合适的呢？不合适的？你们能把它变合适吗？可能吧，我们也能做到。肖恩有个东西要发给你。
Three guys, they're in their fifties, right? Yeah, I think like, yes, yes. And people, the first thing you're gonna say is, these guys are in their fifties? They're in no way. That's the name of the show. That's the name of the show. Those guys are in their fifties in Terabang.
三个家伙，他们都五十岁了，对吧？对，我想，是的，是的。人们，你要说的第一句话会是，这些家伙五十岁了？完全不像。这就是节目的名字。这就是节目的名字。那些家伙在泰拉邦（Terabang）都五十岁了。
We call it, that or we call it Ring Light, the series. And it's just all right. 50 play 35. You've kind of got the concept probably already. I wanna mention, Jason's being also, I know he's geeking out because Mitchell versus the Machines, we talked about it. Man, is that good.
我们管它叫，要么叫这个，要么叫《环形灯：剧集》。这太棒了。50岁的人演35岁。你大概已经理解这个概念了。我想提一下，杰森也很，我知道他对此兴奋不已，因为《米家大战机器人》，我们聊过这个。天哪，那太棒了。
So Jason, I'm gonna let you lose on the boys because it is a great movie. You know, you sit there and you wanna find some time to gobble stuff up with your kid, you know? And you search and you're searching. Well, let's give this thing a try. And oh my God, I did not stop laughing. I was certainly grinning the entire time
所以杰森，我要让你在这帮人面前畅所欲言，因为这是一部伟大的电影。你知道的，你坐在那儿，想找点时间跟你的孩子一起看点东西，你知道吗？然后你搜索，你一直在搜。好吧，我们来看看这个怎么样。哦，天哪，我笑得停不下来。我自始至终都在咧嘴笑
because it was all so fresh, so sharp, so left when you think it's gonna go right. I mean, just everything. That's their homework, man. I know, but like I kept looking over at my, I think I watched it first with my 15 year old and then with my 10 year old. What's it called?
因为它实在太新鲜、太犀利、总是在你以为它要向右转时偏向左边。我是说，简直方方面面都好。那是他们的家庭作业，老兄。我知道，但我一直看着我的，我想我先是和我15岁的孩子一起看，然后又和我10岁的孩子一起看。它叫什么名字？
It's called The Mitchells versus the Machines. Yes. And that's the movie you guys did. I'm sorry. Yeah, we purchased it on Netflix. Yeah. Oh, that's great. And it's just stunningly good.
它叫《米家大战机器人》。对。这就是你们拍的那部电影。不好意思。对，我们在Netflix上看的。哦，太棒了。而且它好得惊艳。
And I was laughing more than they were because it's that smart, that great. Like, it's great. You know, the great animated stuff that works for adults and for kids, it's just, that's not easy. I'm sorry. And then you do, and now you said you're working
我笑得比他们还厉害，因为它就是那么聪明，那么棒。你知道的，那些既适合成年人又适合小孩子的伟大动画作品，这可真不容易。抱歉。然后你们拍了，现在你们说你们正在
on another Spider-Verse movie. It's true. And it should be noted that, I mean, you guys are dipping in, you're one of the only sort of creatives who have been allowed to dip into DC and dip into Marvel. I don't want to make too big of a deal about a less, less than catch wind.
制作另一部《蜘蛛侠：平行宇宙》电影。千真万确。而且值得一提的是，我的意思是，你们正在涉足，你们是极少数被允许同时涉足DC和漫威的创意人员之一。我不想小题大做，以免风声走漏。
Dufflepins. Dufflepins. Lest, but alas, here we are. And that's into the Spider-Verse. Man, that movie, you know, you go when you have preconceived notions, and I shouldn't have, I shouldn't, I went to see it because I love you guys.
杜夫尔别针（Dufflepins）。杜夫尔别针。言归正传，但不管怎样，我们来了。那就是《蜘蛛侠：平行宇宙》。天哪，那部电影，你知道的，你带着先入为主的观念去看了，而我不该这样的，我不应该，我去看了是因为我爱你们。
And I was like, it's going to be, but at the very last minute thinking like, how different can this be? And then just being absolutely blown away by that film. I just, I couldn't have loved it any more. And I don't know. So now I'm thinking, well, you guys are making another one. How are they going to re-break their own mold?
而且我在想，这将会是，但在最后一分钟还在想，这能有多大不同呢？然后就被那部电影彻底震撼了。我简直不能更爱它了。我不知道。所以现在我在想，好吧，你们正在拍另一部。他们将如何再次打破自己的常规？
That has been the real challenge, right? Is that, you know, you don't want to just do the same thing you want. The whole, the brand is innovation. And so then you're like, well, how the hell are we going to make this thing, you know, different from the rest of it? Is that what keeps you guys up?
这才是真正的挑战，对吧？就是，你知道的，你不想只是重复做过的事情，你希望。整个品牌的内核就是创新。所以然后你就会想，好吧，我们到底要怎么把这东西拍得，你知道的，跟以前的不一样？这就是让你们夜不能寐的原因吗？
Is that the thing that you talk about the most? Like across the desk to each other? Yeah, I think we like, that project in particular, you've got, you're sort of freaking out going, how do we recreate the feeling of being in the theater, watching that movie, which is to be surprised. And, but all of these moves that we already did are off the table.
这就是你们讨论得最多的事情吗？隔着桌子看着彼此？对，我想我们喜欢，特别是那个项目，你会有点吓坏了，心想，我们如何重现坐在影院里看那部电影的感觉，那就是感到惊喜。而且，所有我们已经用过的招式都不能再用了。
So you're sitting there going, okay, emotionally, what can we do that will, that will, you know, that will feel like a left turn, but still feel like it's, you know, it belongs there. What about writing something for live, live stage, like a musical play, something like that? We came to, for two seconds, there was a idea of a Lego Broadway show.
所以你坐在那儿想，好吧，在情感上，我们能做点什么，能让人感觉像是一个急转弯，但又觉得它理所当然地属于那里？为真人舞台写点东西怎么样，比如音乐剧、诸如此类的东西？我们曾经，有两秒钟，有过一个关于乐高百老汇秀的想法。
I was like, no, no. It's getting kicked around. And we were thankful that that did not happen. We were like, this seems so hard, which of course makes us want to do it. Sean, don't say no. The guy could have a prosthetic stomach and plastic hair. Yes, exactly, a fat suit and a plastic wig.
当时我就想，不，不。这个想法被讨论过。我们很庆幸那没有发生。我们当时觉得，这看起来太难了，而这当然让我们更想去做了。肖恩，别说不。那家伙可以装一个假肚子和塑料头发。是的，正好，一套肥胖装和一个塑料假发。
Don't think about him. He's like a fat suit, plastic wig. But that notion of like having to better yourselves each time is that I imagine for any artist that creates things from the ground up that there is some sort of an onerous thing that would sit with you. Like, how can I make the next thing better?
别想他了。他就像一套肥胖装，一个塑料假发。但这种每次都必须超越自己的想法，我想对于任何从零开始创作事物的艺术家来说，都是某种会伴随你的沉重负担。比如，我该如何让下一部作品更好？
And do you find that your own taste progresses naturally into a new place of talent? Or do you feel like you guys have to push yourselves to continually grow and be even funnier and be even more sort of subversive? Or does it just happen naturally that your taste just develops? I mean, it's sort of both in that
你们是否发现你们自己的品味会自然而然地发展到一个充满才华的新阶段？还是你们觉得你们必须鞭策自己不断成长，变得更加搞笑，甚至更加具有颠覆性？或者你们的品味自然而然地就发展了？我的意思是，这有点像两者兼有，因为
we don't like to repeat ourselves and we don't like to feel bored. And so, and I don't think we do a very good job unless we feel like we're doing something that we haven't done before that feels like maybe not that many other people have done it before. That kind of drives us.
我们不喜欢重复自己，我们也不喜欢感到无聊。所以，而且如果我们觉得自己做的事情是我们以前没做过的，并且感觉好像没有多少其他人以前做过的话，我们大概就做不出好作品。这种感觉驱动着我们。
So I think sometimes we'll be sitting there going like, why do I hate this? Right. And oh, it's cause it just feels like an easier choice. And so we then, I mean, that's one of the- Which also don't want to be new just for the sake of being new and far out and different. And you have to build this also like fundamentally
所以我想有时我们会坐在那儿想，为什么我这么讨厌这个？对，哦，那是因为这感觉就像是一个更简单的选择。所以然后我们就会，我的意思是，那是其中的一部分——我们也不想为了创新而创新，为了特立独行而特立独行。你还必须从根本上
like universal like relationship things that are not new but every like specific choice has to be different. And I think that the granular sort of embryo of that process is just the conversation between the two of us, which is, you know, yeah, I think this thing is really funny but I'm looking over at Chris and he's just like not having it.
构建这种普遍的人际关系方面的东西，这些东西虽然不是新的，但每一个具体的选择都必须是不同的。而且我认为那个过程的微观“胚胎”其实就是我们俩之间的对话，那就是，你知道的，是的，我觉得这个东西真的很好笑，但我看着克里斯，他却完全不为所动。
So it makes instead of getting mad and going like, why don't you like it? It makes you retreat and go, okay, how can I make this even better? How do I get it up the hill? And maybe Chris can help me. Like here's what I'm going for. Well, this is why I didn't go for it,
所以这不会让你生气并质问说，你为什么不喜欢它？这会让你退一步想，好吧，我该怎么让它变得更好？我怎么把它推上山？也许克里斯能帮我。这就是我的目标。好吧，这就是我不喜欢它的原因，
but maybe you could try. And then you wind up building something that neither one of us would have thought of on our own. It's great having somebody to be like, okay, I'm trying to make this thing that I think Phil is going to like. And luckily our sensibilities are juvenile enough that we can make things that kids seem to like also.
但也许你可以试试。然后你最终会创造出我们任何一个人单打独能都想不出来东西。真庆幸有这样一个人，他能说，好吧，我正在努力创作这个我觉得菲尔会喜欢的东西。幸运的是，我们的品味足够幼稚，能做出小孩子们也喜欢的东西。
But we're never really- That's how Sean and Scotty are with lunch. Yeah. You know what I mean? They're both building towards that they have a similar, there's something that they like and they're like the sandwich and then the tune and the thing and the chips
但我们从来没有真正——肖恩和斯科蒂对午餐就是这样的。对。你知道我的意思吗？他们都在朝着共同的目标努力，他们有相似的品味，有他们喜欢的东西，比如三明治、曲调、那个东西还有薯片，
and they look at each other. Yes. We made it. We made it. We did it. Crack mac and cheese, two boxes. Are you guys proud as you should be that your partnership is healthy
然后他们看着彼此。是的。我们做到了。我们做到了。我们成功了。敲碎通心粉和奶酪，两盒。你们是否像自己应该做的那样，为你们健康、
and that it's harmonious and that you guys still enjoy one another? Cause I'm sure that that takes as much work and attention and respect as you have in your personal relationships and partnerships as well, right? I've got two marriages that I got to let juggle all the time. You know, it's like I'm one of the, I've got like a family in Arizona
和谐、且依然彼此欣赏的合作关系感到骄傲？因为我确信这需要付出与你们在个人关系和合伙关系中同等的工作量、关注和尊重，对吧？我有两段婚姻需要一直在其中左右逢源。你知道的，这就像我是那种，我在亚利桑那州
that that was a secret family. But yeah, so it really is. I mean, the good thing is, you know if you're building it off of respect and admiration and if you feel like, oh, this is a person that's bringing a lot to the table that I can't do and is, you know if you admire the person, it's a lot easier
有一个秘密家庭。但事实确实如此。我的意思是，好的一面是，你知道如果你是以尊重和钦佩为基础来建立这种关系，如果你觉得，哦，这个人带来了很多我做不到的才能，而且，你知道的，如果你钦佩这个人，那就容易多了，
than if you're like, oh, this fucking dead weight. Can you guys identify what one person is better at than the other? Do you guys have clearly two different lanes? It doesn't seem like there's tons of overflows. Write it on a piece of paper and show at the same time. Like is one person better at story and the other person is better at dialogue?
比起你觉得，哦，这特么是个累赘。你们能指出对方更擅长什么吗？你们俩有明确的两条不同赛道吗？好像并没有大量的重叠。把它写在一张纸上，然后同时展示。比如一个人更擅长剧情，而另一个人更擅长对话？
It's not that simple. It would be easier probably if that were the case, but we, you know, we're both, we both have a lot of strong opinions about everything. Yeah, I think we would never find out if one of us was weaker at something because I don't think we'd ever be able to admit it. But I do think there's, sometimes I get a little more
没那么简单。如果真是那样的话可能会简单一些，但我们，你知道的，我们俩对所有事情都有很多强烈的意见。对，我想我们永远不会发现我们之中谁在某方面比较弱，因为我觉得我们永远不会承认这一点。但我确实觉得，有时我会变得更
frustrated or hotheaded in like a meeting and nobody cares, but if Chris gets upset, then everyone pays attention. Because he rarely does? He rarely does. I'm more soft spoken. So Chris is upset and we've been in a few meetings where like somebody said something that was so appalling
沮丧或急躁，尤其是在开会的时候，虽然没人会在意，但如果克里斯生气了，那每个人都会注意。因为他很少这样？他很少这样。我说话比较温和。所以克里斯生气了，我们经历过好几次这样的会议，当时有人说了一些
that Chris like could no longer function. And I immediately flipped into like Mr. Peacemaker, Mr. Constructive, like let's get this together. And I just realized like, oh, I have that muscle. It's just that it's atrophied because Chris is there to pick me up every time I get caught. It's a perfect match.
让克里斯无法再正常工作的话。而我立刻切换成“和平使者先生”、“建设性先生”模式，比如让我们把这事搞定吧。我突然意识到，哦，我其实有这种能力。只是它已经退化了，因为每次我陷入困境时，都有克里斯来拉我一把。这真是绝配。
That's so real. This is incredible. And I like the way that you're like, you don't want to admit it to be like, this is like the equivalent of like keeping it hot. Keep it in there. God, you guys are still dating. And then you guys get to make all these little babies together.
太真实了。这太不可思议了。我喜欢你们这种态度，就是不想承认，就像是相当于在“保持热度”。把它留在里面。天哪，你们俩还在约会。然后你们可以一起生下所有这些小宝宝。
Don't say it like that. And don't fucking shimmy your shoulder. They're making a cartoon baby this time. And the next time they're making a film baby. Phil and Chris, God, we could talk to you guys forever. You guys are the best. Thank you for taking time from your new office. Go make more good stuff.
别那样说。也别特么耸肩膀。他们这次在做一个卡通宝宝。下次他们就要做一个电影宝宝了。菲尔和克里斯，天哪，我们可以跟你们聊上一整天。你们是最棒的。谢谢你们从新办公室里抽出时间来。去创作更多好作品吧。
You guys are so nice. I can't believe you gave us this many compliments. I just expected stern skepticism. No, no, no, no. We're fans. You guys are fans. You guys are really, really nice of you to do this. Thank you guys.
你们人太好了。真不敢相信你们给了我们这么多赞美。我本来只期待严厉的怀疑态度。不，不，不，不。我们是粉丝。你们是粉丝。你们人真的很好，能做这些。谢谢你们。
You guys are the sweetest. Thanks for having us. Chris, say hi to Sissy Poo. I will, I will. I'll tell her you said hello. Thanks. Boys, thank you so much. All the best on after party in the second season.
你们人太甜了。谢谢你们邀请我们。克里斯，代我向西西普问好。我会的，我会的。我会告诉她你向她问好。谢谢。伙计们，非常感谢你们。祝《After Party》第二季一切都好。
Looking forward to everything and just thanks. Good luck with everything. Thank you guys. Thank you fellas. All right. Have a great rest of the day. Bye guys. Bye, bye, bye, bye.
期待所有的一切，再次感谢。祝一切顺利。谢谢你们。谢谢你们，伙计们。好的。祝你们今天剩下的时间过得愉快。再见，伙计们。拜拜，拜拜，拜拜。
Bye. Real good. Real good. So when they, when they double dip, when they do DC and then other times they do Marvel or whatever the other one is, do they just maybe switch their, they go Miller Lord instead of Lord Miller
再见。真不错。真不错。所以当他们，当他们两边通吃，既做DC又做漫威或者别的什么的时候，他们会不会只是换一下名字，变成米勒-洛德而不是洛德-米勒，
and that way people lose track of them. I think when they did Lego movie there were actually a lot of properties involved in that. It just so happens that Warner Brothers has affiliated with the DC brand. Yeah, cause I think they could just switch their names, just go Miller Lord and like they think it's a different couple, you know?
这样人们就记不住他们了？我想他们拍《乐高大电影》的时候，里面其实涉及了很多版权。只不过华纳兄弟恰好和DC品牌有合作关系。对，因为我觉得他们可以换一下名字，就叫米勒-洛德，然后人们会以为那是另一对搭档，你知道吗？
Well, they had everybody in that. I remember one thing was in Lego Batman, there was a line where I say, what's the password? You know, when he's going into the Batcave and I say, Iron Man sucks. And they're like, oh, you can't say that. Sure, sure it's gonna be okay. Yeah, I don't think anybody's gonna mind if I say that.
好吧，他们把所有人都弄进去了。我记得有一件事是在《乐高蝙蝠侠大电影》里，有一句台词是，密码是什么？你知道的，当他走进蝙蝠洞的时候，我说，钢铁侠太烂了。然后他们说，哦，你不能这么说。当然，当然会没事的。是的，我觉得不会有人介意我这么说的。
And we had to go and ask and remember. Yeah. They are, honestly, they are, you know, Jason, you brought up when you go to the movies, especially when you wanna see an animated film and you need a movie. Yeah, those guys are it. Well, that a movie that kind of,
我们不得不去问，还记得吗。他们，老实说，他们是，你知道的，杰森你刚才提到当你去看电影时，尤其是当你想要看一部动画电影并且你需要一部电影的时候。是的，找这俩人准没错。嗯，那部电影，
that appeals to everybody and not in that way of like, hey, you know, the way that executives think like, it's gotta be four quadrant cause they wanna just hit everybody. It's actually really good for everybody. Like really, really good for everybody. Yeah. That's what they do.
能够吸引所有人，而且不是那种高管们思考的那种方式——“必须是面向全年龄段的”（four quadrant），因为他们只想一网打尽。它是真的对所有人都很好。真的是对所有人都非常好。对。这就是他们擅长的。
And it's not like they're doing it in a contrived sort of deliberate strategic way. I think they just, they're just that smart, that funny where there's a little bit for everyone in what makes them laugh. Yeah, I love their stuff. They're just incredible. I truly meant it, working on those Lego movies
而且这并不是说他们是在用一种刻意、深思熟虑的战略方式来做这件事。我想他们只是，他们就是那么聪明，那么搞笑，他们作品中总有一小部分能触动每个人，戳中他们的笑点。对，我爱他们的作品。他们简直不可思议。我是真心实意的，参与制作那些乐高电影
with those dudes. I can't believe they can do everything. They can do big animated films. They can do, they can do live action, ensemble comedy stuff like 21 Jump Street. You know? And then they do this series. And now they got the after party,
跟这群家伙一起。我简直不敢相信他们什么都能做。他们能拍大型动画电影。他们能拍，他们能拍真人喜剧群像戏，比如《龙虎少年团》。你知道吗？然后他们拍了这个系列。现在他们有了《After Party》，
which is a hilarious series. By the way, it's so smart of them to always zigzag because like they said, our brand is an invention or what did they say? Innovation. Their brand is, what did he just say? Is he trying to back into a buy? No, he's not.
这是一部超级搞笑的剧集。顺便说一句，他们总是走“Z”字形路线真是太聪明了，就像他们说的，我们的品牌是发明，或者他们刚才说什么？创新。他们的品牌是，他刚才说什么？他是想顺便买一个吗？不，他不是。
This is the first time that he's actually for legit, I can tell the difference. No, he said our brand is innovative or something like that. Where they, you can't label them as one thing, which is so smart. Yeah, yeah, great. Thanks, Sean.
这是他第一次真正合法的，我能看出区别。不，他说我们的品牌是创新的什么的。他们，你无法把他们归类为单一的某种东西，这太聪明了。对，对，太棒了。谢谢，肖恩。
You know, I know, I just remember what I'm getting Sean for Christmas. Is it a half a brain? It's at the source. Oh, is it a half a brain? I just, I wonder if, it's a scary, I play this game. He's got room.
你知道的，我知道，我刚想好我要送肖恩什么圣诞礼物。是一个半个脑子吗？就在源头。哦，是一个半个脑子吗？我只是，我在想，这是一个可怕的，我玩这个游戏。他还有空间。
I wonder if there's anything wrong in their life. Like everything seems so great. I wonder like, do you think they have some real devious problem like on the weekends that they hope nobody ever finds out about? Yeah, like the double park. Right, those sons of bitches. Those are the ones.
我在想他们生活中是不是有什么不对劲的地方。一切看起来都太美好了。我在想，你觉得他们会不会在周末有一些真正邪恶的问题，希望永远没人发现？对，比如占两个停车位。没错，那群狗娘养的。就是他们。
They're the ones that just kind of straddle the line, you know, because they don't want anyone dinging their door. No, they don't. I think they're probably just really good guys. And you know what? Guys, if you can see the guy, if you can see the glint in his eye,
就是那种故意横跨车位的人，你知道的，因为他们不想让别人的车门碰到他们的车。不，他们才不呢。我觉得他们可能只是真的很好的人。而且你知道吗？伙计们，如果你能看到那个家伙，如果你能看到他眼中的精光，
if we're such a lazy. He's so happy with this one. You know what? You have to say, you know what it rhymes with. This is fucking, even for you, this is so lazy. And I'm gonna allow it because I want you to shame yourself. Go ahead.
如果我们这么懒。他对这个梗太满意了。你知道吗？你得说，你知道这押的是什么韵吗。这特么的，即使对你来说这也太懒了。而我之所以允许它，是因为我想让你感到羞愧。说吧。
Well, it's guy rhymes with, bye! No, that's lazy. It's lazy. You know, it's not, no, you're gonna have to stick around and come up with a bigger one. Yeah, you know what? Let's hang them out. No, we didn't join in.
好吧，guy（伙计）押韵的是……bye（再见）！不，这太懒了。太懒了。你知道的，这不对，不，你得留下来想个更大的。对，你知道吗？让我们悬挂他们。不，我们没参与。
We can't let you have it. Sure. Let's keep going. Let's see. Sean, you know why? Because if I let you go, and if I let that one go today, and then some listeners,
我们不能让你这么过关。当然。让我们继续。来看看吧。肖恩，你知道为什么吗？因为如果我放过你，如果我今天放过那个烂梗，然后一些听众，
you know what that could do? That could come back and, bye! Bye! You and me in the ass! Love you both. Love you. Smart. Less.
你知道那会怎么样吗？那可能会回过头来，拜！拜！咬你的屁股！爱你们俩。爱你们。聪明。少。
Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf, and Bennett Barbaco. Smart. Less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。少。SmartLess 节目是 100% 有机制作，由 Michael Grant Terry、Rob Armjalf 和 Bennett Barbaco 手工匠心打造。聪明。少。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。